[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous à six mois de la présidentielle
donc mobilisation pour remettre les
questions sociales dans le débat
salaires assurance chômage on l'a vu
retraites pourtant il ya eu quelques
augmentations de salaire ici ou là les
professeurs notamment dans la fonction
publique la réforme des retraites elle a
été reportée ça va si mal que ça oui oui
ça va assez mal d'ailleurs cette
mobilisation était en pointillé il n'y a
pas une grande mobilisation on voit bien
que les syndicats la mode d'opération
qui n'est peut-être pas suffisamment
efficace face au rouleau compresseur
qu'est le maquereau nisme parce que ce
que veut faire le vaincrons c'est passer
des réformes extrêmement injuste avant
la fin du quinquennat la réforme des
retraites qui a été mise en pause un par
les syndicats justement qu'ils pensaient
qu'il n'avait pas lieu d'être et le co
vite la réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui est passé par décret alors même que
le conseil d'état avait dit que c'était
peut-être pas le moment tout ça c'est
des réformes qui vont contre les plus
pauvres les plus précaires même si
évidemment quelques salaires ont été
augmentés parce qu'il le fallait ça fait
tellement longtemps que les salaires de
fonctionnaires ont été gelés que ça
commençait à se voir qu'on ne pouvait
plus vivre avec son salaire les gilets
jaunes rappelez vous c'est ce mouvement
qui commence parce que on a beaucoup de
français dans ce pays qui ne peuvent pas
joindre les deux bouts qui travaillent
et qui ne peuvent pas finir le mois et
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose on remet
évidemment la question du pouvoir
d'achat la question qui est central de
dire mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
vivre avec un salaire et beaucoup de
français prennent de plein fouet c'est
mesure ces réformes qui sont soit disant
progressistes mais qui en réalité plonge
dans la précarité de nombreux français
alors attaqué un par un les oppositions
l'exécutif mais met en avant son bilan 1
pour montrer que le quinquennat a
profité à l'ensemble de la population il
faut bien le dire que les chiffres de
l'insee avons plutôt dans ce sens du
progrès du pouvoir d'achat sur le
quinquennat macro c'est pas moi qui le
dit céline cécile emmanuel macron
clairement il veut tfc sont son image de
président des riches alors oui c'est ça
lui colle à la peau mais parce que c'est
vrai l'insee d'ailleurs sur le site
étaient en rade aujourd'hui j'ai voulu
aller voir justement linselles des
dommages ah oui c'est très dommage donc
j'ai dit mémé lycée qu'est ce qui se
passe vous faites un peu une facebook
aujourd'hui
mais il ya des chiffres qui sont là et
qui disent que ça va mieux apparemment
on peut gagner plus d'argent sous mac os
elodie la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation a bénéficié à plus de 17
millions de français oui la réforme de
la taxe d'habitation ces 200 euros de
plus dans la poche de quelques français
la réforme de l'isf l'impôt sur la
fortune qui se transforme en impôt sur
le patrimoine immobilier
c'est à peu près trois cent trente mille
français qui eux ont gagné neuf mille
euros toutes les réformes des manuels
macro ont profité aux plus riches en
réalité et vous avez des sondages qui
passait un peu comme la température à
vous avez la température réelle la
température ressentie vous avez ce que
pense emmanuel macron qui vit dans un
pays font face mais où il dit j'ai fait
des réformes pour le poire d'achat et
puis le pouvoir d'achat ressenti et là
les français ils sont majoritairement à
se dire que les réformes des revenus
macron ont amputé leur pouvoir d'achat
que ça ne va pas mieux et d'ailleurs
aucune réforme aujourd'hui n'a bénéficié
à l'économie on attend de voir les
résultats il n'y a jamais eu de
ruissellement et des quelques réformes
qui ont été faites ont certes dans les
chiffres l'insee bien sûr les tableaux
de calcul des certitudes conseil
emmanuel macron lui-même pense que ça va
bien mais que demander aux français à
ceux qui font aujourd'hui la queue
devant les banques alimentaires aux
banques alimentaires qui manquent de
bras qui recrutent des bénévoles
tellement la demande a explosé plus de
huit millions selon des associations 2
millions en début d'année des français
qui n'avaient jamais fait appel aux
banques alimentaires avant cela les
étudiants qui font aussi la queue pour
se nourrir c'est ça augmente et pouvoir
d'achat des gens qui sont dans la
paupérisation extrême non je crois pas
donc il ya vraiment deux mondes le monde
des modèles macron où tout va bien woods
est le meilleur président du monde où ça
va extrêmement bien et puis le pays dans
lequel vivent les français qui
visiblement n'est pas le même que celui
des modèles maquereau ou là le ressenti
n'est pas du tout le même alors on a
beaucoup parlé évidemment de
l'immigration en sept ans on est bien
rendu compte mais le vrai enjeu des
présidentielles ça sera justement le
pouvoir d'achat oui je crois que ces
débats sur l'identité sur l'immigration
ses biens cédés débat d'intellectuels de
saint germain les français s'en foutent
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils
veulent savoir qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer parce que si on lui demande de
rembourser la dette qu'ovide qui est
catastrophique
si on demande de faire des efforts sur
les finances publiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui le maquereau est en
campagne donc il fait des cadeaux des
promesses à tout le monde la réalité
c'est qu'après sa réélection s'il est
réélu ou peu importe qui va arriver aux
commandes de ce pays il va retrouver un
pays endetté à l'extrême un pays avec
des services publics met à genoux
regardez aujourd'hui c'est pas 3000
soignants qui ont été mis à pied c'est
beaucoup plus 1400 rien qu'un en ile de
france l'hôpital public qui se demande
s'il va pouvoir assurer sa mission les
professeurs qui ne savent plus comment
faire pour assurer les missions de
service public tout ça c'est le pays
dans lequel on vit en réalité donc non
ça va mal évidemment et les français le
ressentent et aujourd'hui le plan à part
les promesses de campagne il n'y en a
pas et c'est ça qui est extrêmement
dangereux je pense et se gâtent us entre
ce que pensent les élites à la majorité
au pouvoir et ce que vivent les français
et c'est pour ça qu'on a autant de monde
dans la rue alors pas avec les syndicats
ça a été très peu de monde aujourd'hui
mais quand on lutte contre le pass and i
terre quand on lutte pour le pouvoir
d'achat c'est elle et gilet jaune ils ne
sont pas morts loin de là et je crois
qu'on va voir au contraire un regain de
ce mouvement parce qu'on se rend compte
que les promesses de campagne ne
suffisent pas aujourd'hui l'inflation
est réel les produits de première
nécessité explose le logement explose
l'énergie on en parlait la semaine
dernière les prix d'énergie explose et
rien n'est fait par les pouvoirs publics
pour empêcher cette catastrophe sociale
merci beaucoup alexis poulain en direct
donc il dit aurélie sur rt france